bonjour à tous à examen aujourd'hui du
projet de loi sur la gendarmerie à la
réforme défendu par michèle alliot-marie
vise à placer l la gendarmerie sous
l'autorité du ministère de l'intérieur
une réforme historique selon le
gouvernement est la précédente date de
mais le ps se dit fermement opposé à ce
projet de loi est les sénateurs
socialistes estiment que cette réforme
démantèle la gendarmerie à voilà pour
l'essentiel nous partons tout de suite
en séance alors dans la discussion
générale
la parole est justement est à madame
michèle alliot marie ministre de
l'intérieur de l'outre-mer et des
collectivités territoriales
monsieur le président messieurs les
présidents messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs les
événements de ce jour soulignent les
exigences de la sécurité au service de
la protection de nos concitoyens
vous le savez ce matin à la suite d'une
revendication que l afp ont été
découvertes dans un grand magasin des
bâtons de dynamite entouré d'un cordon
qui heureusement ne contenait pas les
éléments que susceptibles de produire
une détonation mais il est évident que
ceci est une préoccupation la
revendication que de ce dépôt a été
faite par un groupe qui est inconnu de
tous nos services de sécurité les forces
de l'ordre ont immédiatement réagi
puisque avec une très grande réactivité
a été mise en place à la fois un cordon
de sécurité bloquant les rues de
récentes on a procédé à l'évacuation des
personnes qui se trouvaient dans ce
grand magasin bien entendu quelques
jours avant noël
c'était particulièrement nombreuses et
on a bien entendu fait les perquisitions
nécessaire qui nous ont permis de
trouver cette charge
l'enquète est évidemment que en cour
aujourd'hui pour essayer de déterminer
l'origine de ces bâtons de dynamite
ainsi que les auteurs à la fois du dépôt
qui est de la rendre indications et pour
pouvoir les interpeller et les traduire
devant la justice
par ailleurs
et compte tenu du fait que nous sommes
dans une période sensible j'ai décidé de
renforcer les effectifs employés à la
sécurisation à paris et dans les grandes
villes de province
et dès demain je tiendrai une réunion
consacrée à la sécurité en cette période
sensible avec les services de police et
de gendarmerie les services de
renseignement
la ratp la sncf et les renseignements
des grands magasins ainsi bien entendu
que les aéroports de paris il s'agit
nous prendre les choses bien entendu
avec la prudence et la sérénité
nécessaire il s'agit aussi d'être
vigilants et déterminés et c'est ce que
nous faisons chaque fois que la sécurité
de nos concitoyens se trouve en jeu
lover ceci a bien entendu un rapport
aussi très directe avec le projet de loi
que j'ai l'honneur de voeux présentés à
la haute assemblée aujourd'hui
en effet ce projet de loi concerne la
gendarmerie comme cela a été dit et il
organise le rattachement organique et
budgétaire de la gendarmerie nationale
au ministère de l'intérieur
je n'ai pas besoin de le dire
particulièrement ici la gendarmerie et
une force armée chargée de la sûreté et
de la sécurité publique
elle est aujourd'hui elle le restera
demain depuis la loi de germinal en 6
aucune loi n'avait été adoptée sur le
statut et les missions de la gendarmerie
nationale c'est un premier élément
important
et d'autre part il faut également noter
que c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de notre république que les
deux forces de sécurité civile et
militaire seront placés sous la
responsabilité pleine et entière du
ministre de l'intérieur
même si cela doit être souligné aussi
depuis 2002 la gendarmerie a déjà été
placées tour emploi pour ses missions
sur le territoire
auprès du ministre et sous la
responsabilité du ministre de
l'intérieur
mais au moment que où je voulais dit je
souhaite constituer un grand ministère
moderne de la protection des français
ce rattachement est important et la
gendarmerie nationale doit y tenir toute
sa place au service de la protection des
français et le projet de loi vise
finalement à faire une chose après le
rattachement s'est donnée à la
gendarmerie
les moyens de participer ainsi
pleinement à la constitution de ce grand
ministère moderne de la protection des
français au projet de loire répond ainsi
à une exigence de modernisation et
d'efficacité dans le même temps parce
que je considère aussi que c'est une
condition d'efficacité de modernisation
il conforte l'identité militaire de la
gendarmerie mettez moi de vous le dire
le rattachement de la gendarmerie au
ministère de l'intérieur est logique
l'environnement de la sécurité
intérieure évolue son organisation doit
évoluer pour être adaptées aussi à cette
évolution générale le poids des missions
intérieures de la sécurité de la sanzar
mairie avait je vous rappeler tout à
l'heure justifier leur attachement pour
emploi en 2002 au ministère de
l'intérieur
et bien aujourd'hui il est logique et il
faut aller au bout de la démarche
la séparation entre les missions et les
moyens
vous l'avez souvent souligné dans cette
haute assemblée se révèle artificiel dès
lors que l'on confie des missions il
faut que les moyens nécessaires aux
missions soit géré de la même façon
confié aux responsables de l'emploi le
budget
c'est une exigence de rationalité et
d'efficacité d'ailleurs l'esprit de la
lolf et temporairement les contraintes
budgétaires impose plus que jamais la
cohérence des actions de l'état que la
mission sécurité dépendent du ministre
de l'intérieur à travers les deux
programmes police nationale et
gendarmerie nationales et donc quelque
chose de logique et d'ailleurs va nous
permettre
penser parce que les mutualisations les
regroupements de marché qui sont ainsi
facilitée par ce rapprochement de la
gestion des moyens va nous permettre
d'améliorer à la fois les coûts et aussi
l'interopérabilité entre les forces de
la police nationale et les forces de la
gendarmerie nationale deuxièmement il
faut bien voir également que rattacher
la gendarmerie au ministère de
l'intérieur va nous permettre de
moderniser un certain nombre de
procédures qui datait pour un certain
nombre d'entre elles du 19e siècle et il
en va ainsi de l'abandon de la procédure
de réquisition pour l'engagement des
unités de gendarmerie au maintien
alors je vais insister un tout petit peu
là dessus parce que je sais que ça fait
débat y compris au sein de vos
commissions
je veux rappeler simplement une chose
c'est qu'est ce que c'est que la
réquisition la réquisition ce qui permet
à l'autorité civile de disposer de
moyens et notamment des forces armées
dont elle ne dispose pas normalement
organiquement pour le maintien de
l'ordre
c'est effectivement un héritage de la
révolution
je le rappelle qui avait été ensuite
conscrits dans le code de la défense
mais dès lors que la gendarmerie et
placé sous l'autorité du ministre de
l'intérieur
cette procédure formelle n'a plus lieu
d'être quand bien même la gendarmerie
reste une force militaire il n'est quand
même assez peu cohérent que le ministre
soit contraint de requérir une force
dont il dispose parce que c'est ça le
problème
alors ça ne veut pas dire mais non pas
du tout elle la gendarmerie ne perd pas
le statut et d'ailleurs je vais vous le
dire
cela ne veut pas dire d'ailleurs que
tout formalisme me disparaît
personne n'imagine par exemple que pour
l'emploi des véhicules blindés
l'autorisation du premier ministre ou
par délégation celle du préfet de zone
puissent être supprimés ça il n'en est
pas question
dès lors qu'il ya des moyens importants
cela se fait tout naturellement
mais il faut aussi avoir un minimum de
logique et d'ailleurs vos commissions
c'est ptet le principe de l'abandon de
la réquisition mais un dispositif
réglementaire à leurs demandes permettra
effectivement d'encadrer le recours à
des moyens qui sont des moyens lourds
des moyens militaires spécifiques ou à
usage des armes les plus significatives
en cas de besoin le maintien de l'ordre
public nous le savons tous exigent de la
maîtrise du sang froid de la mesure de
la retenue c'est d'ailleurs une des
caractéristiques des forces de l'ordre
françaises est une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous servons souvent de
référence et d'exemples à l'étranger et
ceci est vrai aussi bien pour les forces
déployées sur le terrain que pour les
chefs que pour les autorités civiles
gendarmes et policiers sont formés sont
préparés sont entraînés dans cet état
d'esprit
et quand on compare la façon dont se
gère les mêmes événements y compris chez
un certain nombre de nos grands voisins
et qu'il s'agisse des états unis ou
qu'il s'agisse d'un certain nombre
d'autres grands pays et chez nous on
voit bien la différence et on voit ce
rôle que joue la formation vous avez pu
mais oui je pense que et je suis fier de
dire et de temps en temps il faut savoir
dire que nous sommes les meilleurs parce
qu'effectivement c'est reconnaître à
leur juste titre les qualités des
policiers des gendarmes français
soyons lucides nous ne sommes cependant
pas malgré cette lectrice à l'abri d'un
incident grave et c'est donc la raison
pour laquelle je prépare aussi parce que
je veux que les choses soient claires je
prépare une instruction permanente sur
le maintien de l'ordre qui regard en
tice la traçabilité des ordres donnés en
toutes circonstances je veux savoir qui
fait quoi et je souhaite d'ailleurs
aussi et les responsables le savent le
savent qu'il puisse y avoir chaque fois
qu'il y a des engagements
des images qui soit tournée en
permanence parce que j'en ai un peu
assez de voir des images qui sont
tournés à partir d'un certain nombre de
téléphones portables et qui ne montre
que ce que l'on veut bien montrer
eh bien je pense que comme ça ça évitera
effectivement un certain nombre de
polémiques stériles qui met injustement
en cause les forces de l'ordre en
oubliant trop souvent les provocations
dont elles sont l'objet préalablement
deuxième élément de modernisation c'est
l'articulation claire de l'autorité du
préfet et du commandement militaire
là aussi je sais il il ya eu un certain
nombre de débats qui se sont produits
dans vos commissions et d'ailleurs j'ai
déjà eu à répondre devant les
commissions de ceux ci je veux
simplement rappeler une chose c'est que
depuis six ans sans que me soient
remontés nico ministre de la défense me
comme ministre de l'intérieur aucun
signe de difficulté
cette articulation entre ce que fait le
préfet est ce que fait le commandement
militaire des gendarmes s'est déroulé
sur le terrain à de nombreuses occasions
lui l'autorité du représentant de l'état
s'exerce déjà sur les services de police
bien sûr et sur les unités de
gendarmerie le fit le préfet fixe les
missions était la moindre des choses
la hiérarchie militaire de la
gendarmerie détermine elle les moyens
opérationnels d'organisation et
d'exécution de la mission puis ce
commandement rend compte de l'exécution
de ses missions et des résultats obtenus
au préfet c'est quelque chose qui se
passe et c'est ce que nous inscrivons
dans la loi ni le préfet ni ses
collaborateurs non à s'immiscer dans le
détail de l'organisation ou de
l'exécution du service
d'ailleurs ils n'en n'ont pas la
formation
la plupart du temps sauf quand il s'agit
effectivement de préfet qui viennent de
la gendarmerie y en a un certain nombre
mesdames et messieurs silga
modernisation il doit aussi y avoir et
d'une façon d'eternit maintien d'un
certain nombre de principes et dans ses
principes auxquels je tiens vous le
savez surtout c'est bon parce que vous
m'avez souvent entendues au cours de ces
derniers mois et de ces dernières années
le dire c'est que la gendarmerie est un
des piliers de la république en
confortant son identité militaire
le projet de loi réaffirme sa place au
coeur de notre pacte républicain
parce que et je vais le redire une
nouvelle fois parce que c'est ma
conviction profonde
la france a besoin d'une force de
sécurité à statut militaire et là nous
avons les bases de la démocratie et de
la république
héritière d'une longue histoire
la gendarmerie a toujours su démontrer
sa capacité d'adaptation
grâce notamment à l'éventail de ses
savoir faire qui est une de ses
caractéristiques et à ses compétences la
gendarmerie assure et doit continuer
d'assurer la couverture du territoire
national aussi bien en métropole
qu'outre-mer elle s'est alliée les modes
d'action militaire et l'exercice de la
police administrative et judiciaire
et ceci dans des conditions parfois
difficiles
elle le démontre et je pense que nous
pouvons tous salué ce qui se fait
notamment en guyane dans la lutte contre
l'orpaillage
et c'est parce que je fais ce que font
les gendarmes et je trouve qu'ils
doivent en être remerciée parce que
c'est souvent très difficile qu'ils
essuient régulièrement des coups de feu
ils travaillent dans des conditions
effectivement particulièrement ardue la
gendarmerie c'est aussi se mobiliser par
à tout moment en temps de paix en temps
de crise voire même en temps de guerre
et sa présence au sein de la mission de
l'union européenne en géorgie au kosovo
en côte d'ivoire notamment en sont
l'illustration
et n'oublions pas que c'est autour
d'elle que j'ai pu créer la force
européenne de gendarmerie qui est un
outil de gestion de crise de sortie de
crise sans équivalent et que cela a
entraîné l'adhésion de nos 27
partenaires la gendarmerie c'est ne
l'oublions jamais une condition
d'effectivité de la démocratie dans sa
traduction quotidienne son encadrement
ses valeurs son esprit de discipline
aussi lui dicte le strict respect des
droits de la personne humaine en toutes
circonstances et je les ai vus en de
nombreuses circonstances
elle garantit aussi aux magistrats le
libre choix dans l'exercice de la police
judiciaire et ça aussi c'est une base de
notre démocratie
elle assure la continuité de l'état sur
tous les territoires de la république
l'équilibré entre police et gendarmerie
est le corollaire de cette double
participation à la protection de nos
concitoyens
il n'est pas question d'aller vers une
fusion de la police et de la gendarmerie
et je le dis très nettement ici et
j'espère messieurs que tout le monde
partage ce point de vue j'espère que
vous saurez le dire sans aucune
restriction
et cela sera die
or au delà de ma personne la meilleure
garantie pour les gendarmes de ce qu'ils
conserveront toujours leur statut
militaire
j'espère donc sur ce point j'aurais
votre unanimité mesdames et messieurs
parce que sinon cela laisserait entendre
que vous avez derrière la tête d'autres
idées qui sont radicalement opposées aux
miennes en la matière il n'est pas
question de fusion entre la police et la
gendarmerie
le président de la république l'a
affirmé chacune de ces institutions à sa
culture son histoire son identité et la
différence des statuts est un atout pour
notre pays et dans le même temps
l'équilibré doit être respecté entre la
police et la gendarmerie
l' équilibre la complémentarité des
missions il s'agisse de police
judiciaire d'ordre public de
renseignements ou d'international
l'équilibré le respect des zones de
compétence ensuite il n'est pas question
de détourner les effectifs de la
gendarmerie pour renforcer au quotidien
la police nationale dans sa zone de
compétence
ce qui n'empêche pas en tant que de
besoin qu'il puisse y avoir un soutien
en homme comme cela est nécessaire
lors d'une crise ou d'une situation
particulière je crois que d'ores et déjà
policiers et gendarmes ont l'habitude de
se prêter main forte dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles équilibre
enfin par la parité de traitement dans
le respect des différences de statut
c'est également un point auquel je suis
attaché
et j'ai mis les structures en place pour
que cette parité soit respectée tout en
respectant les spécificités des statuts
mesdames
oui c'est vrai nous ne mettre que des
hommes là mais faudrait peut être faire
un petit effort
ah oui pardonnez moi un sursis sera
marqué au delà ils auraient peur c'est
bon pardon nous sommes en dehors de ça
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs donc
le projet de loi qui vous est soumis
conforte le statut militaire de la
gendarmerie
il définit la gendarmerie allez allez
messieurs à soyaux je pense que c'est un
sujet suffisamment sérieux on nous
regarde
je pense que c'est un vrai sujet quand
je pense que le débat effectivement
exigent de leur sexe et la wii en
attendant c'est moi qui suis ici mais on
n'avait pas fait la même chose
le projet de loi définit donc la
gendarmerie comme une force armées
institués pour veiller à la sûreté et la
sécurité publique
il fixe ses missions en rappelant
qu'elle participe à la défense de la
patrie et des intérêts supérieurs de la
nation
il répartit les attributions des
ministres de l'intérieur de la défense
et de l'autorité judiciaire en
soulignant celle du ministre de la
défense en particulier pour l'exécution
des missions militaires
il précise les suggestions et
obligations imposées aux officiers et
sous-officiers en matière d'emploi et de
logement cazin il renforce ainsi la
capacité de la gendarmerie nationale
assurer ses missions à tout moment et en
tout lieu de sa zone de compétence
plusieurs mesures d'ailleurs en découle
d'abord le recrutement dans les grandes
écoles militaires
il contribue à former des gendarmes qui
reçoivent les bases de l'éthique et du
savoir faire propre à la gendarmerie
ce recrutement dans les grandes écoles
militaires sera maintenu contrairement à
ce que certains de vos amis quand je
suis arrivé au ministère de la défense
avait prévu puisque les gendarmes ont
échappé si je puis dire pour leur
formation aux grandes écoles militaires
je pense que c'était une erreur je l'est
resté
j'ai inscrit donc cela dans la loi de
façon à ce qu'aucun sur vauban en
particulier ne puisse revenir sur ce
sujet deuxièmement la participation aux
opérations extérieures
elle permettra aux militaires de la
gendarmerie de cultiver les valeurs
militaires et de renforcer leurs liens
avec leurs camarades des armées enfin la
défense continuera d'assurer une partie
des soutiens qu'il s'agisse par exemple
de santé le service de santé des armées
continuera d'être compétent pour les
militaires la gendarmerie qu'il s'agisse
du paiement de la solde qu'il s'agisse
du transport opérationnel j'ai passé
avec le ministre de la défense 30
convention qui dans trente domaines
différents perpétue le soutien du
ministère de la défense pour les
militaires de la gendarmerie
la concertation dans la gendarmerie
restera elle aussi soumise aux règles en
vigueur au sein de la défense le
ministre de l'intérieur sera toutefois
appelé à co présider le conseil de la
fonction militaire de la gendarmerie
la création des groupements
professionnels par voie logique de
conséquence continuera bien entendu
d'être proscrite
parce qu'elle n'est ni souhaitable ni
nécessaire le statut militaire que j'ai
modifié en 2005 garantit aux militaires
une très large liberté d'expression mais
il est hors de question qu'il puisse y
avoir des syndicats chez les militaires
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
projet de loi soumis à votre examen
repose vous le voyez sur une vision
exigeante de la protection des français
une vision moderne soucieuse d'adapter
larchitecture de notre sécurité
intérieure aux défis nombreux qui sont
ceux du 21e siècle une vision aussi
pragmatique
consciente des atouts d'une force
militaire de sécurité pour notre action
quotidienne
sur le terrain une vision ambitieuse
fondée sur l'efficacité la coordination
la réactivité des deux forces de
sécurité au service des citoyens
cette vision mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est la mienne c'est celle du
gouvernement
c'est celle j'en ai la conviction des
membres de votre haute assemblée et je
vous en remercie
comment vous en remercieront les
militaires de la gendarmerie qui savent
votre reconnaissance votre détermination
et votre soutien je vous remercie le
ministre
la parole est à notre collègue monsieur
jean faure rapporteur de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées
ravageurs
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
tout d'abord avant d'aborder le texte je
voudrais vous dire à quel esprit nous
avons abordé votre projet de loi nous
l'avons abordé ni pour servir la
gendarmerie ni pour servir la police ni
pour rendre service au ministère de
l'intérieur au ministère des finances
nous l'avons abordée avec un seul esprit
c'est de rendre service aux français et
ce projet de loi nous y sommes sensibles
parce que d'abord nous sommes saisis en
premier c'est un caractère historique
puisque depuis la loi du 28 germinal en
6 c'est à dire depuis 1798
aucune loi n'a été adoptée sur
l'organisation et les missions nageant
mameri les règles régissant le statut et
les missions d'un gendarmerie nationale
repose sur un simple décret qui date de
1903 au delà de son caractère historique
ce projet de loi comporte des
innovations majeures
ainsi ce texte organise le transfert de
la tutelle organisera ministère
l'intérieur conformément à la volonté
exprimée par le président de la
république dans son discours du 29
novembre 2007
cette mesure constitue une profonde
réforme pour une institution placée
depuis l'origine sous l'autorité du
ministre de la défense
avant même l'annoncé de cette réforme la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense avait décidé de constituer en
son sein un groupe de travail chargé de
réfléchir à l'avenir de l'organisation
d'un gendarmerie secondes de travail que
j'ai eu l'honneur de présider était
composé de mes collègues michel domicile
hubert haenel philippe madrelle charles
pasqua il posait au lit borgo et andré
rouvière de décembre 2007 à mars 2008
notre groupe de travail a procédé à une
quarantaine d'auditions et à plusieurs
déplacements sur le terrain à lucid nos
travaux nous avons présenté 17
recommandations qui ont été adaptés
adoptée à l'unanimité par là commission
est publiée dans un rapport
d'information que vous avez eue en avril
dernier pour l'examen du projet de loi
je ne suis fondu sur ses recommandations
j'ai également entendu une quinzaine de
personnalités dont les représentants des
différents ministères mais aussi des
anciens directeurs généraux et des
officiers de gendarmerie des préfets des
magistrats et des représentants
d'associations de retraités
j'ai voulu m'inspirer madame le ministre
d'une phrase qui figure dans le
préambule du décret du 20 mai 1903 et
qui dit la chose suivante il faut bien
définir la part d'actions que chaque
département ministériel peut exercer sur
la gendarmerie afin de sauvegarder cette
arme contre les exigences qui ne pouvait
trouver leur prétexte que dans
l'élasticité où l'obscurité de quelques
artistes
si l'issue de ces travaux j'ai proposé
donc dix huit amendements qui ont tous
été adoptés par la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense de
notre assemblée
à cet égard je voudrais saluer ici le
travail en commun et la grande
convergence de vue avec la commission
des lois
son président bien sûr et son rapporteur
pour avis notre collègue jean patrick
courtois
la plupart des amendements adoptés par
nos deux commissions sont en effet très
proches et complémentaires
quelles sont les principales
préoccupations qui ressortent de ces
amendements
comme vous l'avez rappelé madame le
ministre lors de votre audition devant
nous deux commissions ce rattachement
constituent moins une rupture que
l'aboutissement d'une évolution
commencée en 2002 en effet depuis un
décret du 15 mai 2002 la gendarmerie
nationale est placée pour emploi auprès
du miso l'intérieur pour l'exercice de
ses missions de sécurité intérieure et
plus récemment en 2007 a été posée une
responsabilité conjointe du ministre
l'intérieur et du miz de la défense
concernant la définition des moyens
budgétaires de la gendarmerie et de son
fuient dit ainsi on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui la gendarmerie dépend
déjà largement du ministre de
l'intérieur
toutefois le système a que les bancal
car le ministère de l'intérieur
responsable de l'emploi de la
gendarmerie
mais ils ne disposent pas des deux
leviers importants que sont le budget et
la gestion des carrières qui constituent
de relever du ministre de la défense le
rattachement de la gendarmerie au
ministre de l'intérieur permettra de
réaliser l'unicité de commandement et de
renforcer la coopération entre la police
et gendarmerie en matière de lutte
contre la criminalité
rappelons que les missions de sécurité
intérieure représente 95 % d'activité de
la gendarmerie contre seulement 5% de
ses missions militaires
il permettra ainsi d'améliorer la
protection des français
ce rapprochement permettra aussi de
développer les mutualisations et les
synergies des moyens entre les deux
forces
ainsi les hélicoptères nous les entendre
ils pourront être engagées au profit des
deux forces
ce qui évitera de créer une deuxième
flotte très coûteuse
de même la mutualisation pour être
développées notamment pour l'achat des
équipements de soutien logistique ou
encore les systèmes d'information et de
communication
ainsi ce rapprochement favorisera les
économies d'échelle et sera source
d'économie pour les contribuables
le rattachement de la gendarmerie
nationale ou ministre de l'intérieur ne
doit pas entraîner et vous l'avez
rappelé solennellement
la disparition du statut militaire de
leurs danses gendarmerie nationale et sa
fusion avec la police la dualité des
deux forces de sécurité l'une un statut
civil la police nationale l'autre à
statut militaire la gendarmerie
nationale n'est pas seulement un
héritage historique ce principe
constitue une garantie pour l'état
républicain
hans et les citoyens comme l'a rappelé
le président de la république nous avons
besoin dans notre pays d'une force de
sécurité à statut militaire capable de
faire face à des situations de crise en
métropole outre mer ou sur les théâtres
d'opérations extérieures ce principe
n'est pas remis en cause par le projet
de loi
celui-ci préserve le statut militaire de
la gendarmerie nationale qui tout en
étant placé sous l'autorité du miso
intérieure restera une force armée pour
ses missions militaires la gendarmerie
sans que c'est sous l'autorité du
ministre de la défense qui continuera
également d'exercer la compétence en
matière de discipline
les officiers et sous-officiers de
gendarmerie resteront donc des
militaires soumis au statut général des
militaires afin de garantir la parité
globale de traitement avec les polices
ils disposeront d'une grille spécifique
les amendements présentés par notre
commission vise principalement à
préserver le statut militaire la
gendarmerie a conforté ses missions et
son ancrage territorial
nous avons ainsi proposé de réécrire
l'article du projet de loi relatif aux
missions de la gendarmerie afin
notamment de rappeler sa vocation
première
veiller à l'exécution des lois assurer
l'ordre et la sécurité publics dans les
zones rurales et périurbaines nos
amendements disent également assurer un
équilibre entre efficacité de l'action
en matière de lutte contre la
crimininalité et le respect des libertés
publiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle tout en
approuvant la suppression de la
procédure de réquisition pour l'emploi
des gens dans
au maintien de l'ordre il nous a semblé
indispensable de maintenir un minimum de
formalisme pour l'emploi des moyens
militaires comme les véhicules blindés
ou pour l' usage des armes de certaines
catégories tant par les gendarmes que
par les policiers personne n'imagine en
effet que des véhicules blindés puis
cette employée pour le maintien de
l'ordre sans l'ordre écrit de l'autorité
politique afin de préserver le dualisme
policiers nous avons également souhaité
rappeler le rôle essentiel joué par la
gendarmerie en matière de police
judiciaire et inscrire dans la partie
législative du code de procédure pénale
le principe du libre choix du service
enquêteur
ce principe qui permet aux magistrats de
ne pas dépendre d'un seul service pour
réaliser leur enquête constitue en effet
une garantie fondamentale d'indépendance
de l'autorité judiciaire
enfin il nous a semblé utile d'inscrire
dans ce projet de loi l'obligation du
logement en caserne qui participe de la
disponibilité et de la proximité des
gendarmes avec la population et les élus
locaux
je sais madame que nous avons sur l'un
de ces amendements
une petite divergence avec le
gouvernement je veux parler de celui
concernant l'autorité des préfets sur
les commandements locaux de gendarmerie
entendons nous bien ne s'agit pas pour
nous de vouloir remettre en cause le
rôle de direction et de coordination du
préfet le représentant de l'état dans le
département en matière de sécurité
notre préoccupation porte sur le respect
du principe hiérarchique qui est ce
qu'on substantielle du statut militaire
une autre de nos préoccupations portent
sur le respect des zones de compétence
de la police et de la gendarmerie
alors la question qui est posée et je
pense que nous aurons l'occasion d'avoir
une réponse tout à l'heure sinon
risque-t-on pas d'aboutir à ce que les
gendarmes soient appelés en renfort des
policiers dans les grandes
agglomérations ce qui est légitime au
détriment de la sécurité dans les zones
rurales ou périurbaines qui constituent
pourtant leur vocation première
je ne doute pas que nous parviendrons à
trouver une formulation qui répondent à
ces préoccupations
enfin le rattachement de la gendarmerie
au ministre de l'intérieur pose la
question de la coexistence d'une force
armée telles que la gendarmerie une
d'une force de police nationale où le
syndicalisme est reconnue vous l'avez
aussi rappelé très très clairement dès
lors que les gendarmes et les policiers
sont placées sous une tutelle unique
comment éviter que s'expriment des
revendications accrue tant dans un
alignement des deux statues qui
aboutirait inévitablement un effacement
du statut militaire des gendarmes et et
sa fusion la police disons les choses
clairement
le syndicalisme est par nature
incompatible avec le statut militaire
donc la gendarmerie doit continuer le
relevé des instances de concertation
propose armés toutefois il paraît
nécessaire de définir de nouvelles
modalités de participation du ministère
de l'intérieur aux instances de
concertation la gendarmerie les règles
relatives au fonctionnement des
instances de concertation relève pour
l'essentiel du domaine réglementaire et
c'est pour cela que nous n'avons pas
souhaité modifier le projet de loi sur
ce point je pense toutefois utile madame
le ministre que vous nous inquiète
l'indiqué quelles mesures seront prises
pour assurer la coexistence harmonieuse
des deux forces au sein de votre
ministère
la principale force de la gendarmerie ce
sont des femmes et des hommes qui
témoignent quotidiennement par leur
disponibilité leur dévouement leur
sacrifice parfois de leur engagement au
service de la population ou non de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense je veux leur témoigner ici notre
reconnaissance pour leur action au
service de la sécurité des français
sous réserve des amendements que je
viens de vous présenter la commission
affaires étrangères de la défense vous
proposant d'adopter ce texte de loi
merci jean faure la parole est un autre
collègue monsieur jean patrick courtois
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des droits mais si le président madame
le ministre mes chers collègues le
gouvernement à adopter est déposé en
premier lieu cela convient d'être
soulignée sur le bureau du sénat le
projet de loi portant dispositions
relatives à la gendarmerie
répondant à la demande formulée par le
président de la république dans son
discours du 29 novembre 2007
ce projet de loi organise le
rattachement de la gendarmerie nationale
au ministère de l'intérieur sur
rattachement organique est
l'aboutissement logique d'une évolution
entamée en 2002 avec le placement de la
gendarmerie pour emploi auprès de ce
ministère
il s'accompagne simultanément d'une
réaffirmation du statut militaire de la
gendarmerie conditions nécessaires au
maintien du dualisme policiers français
compte tenu de l'attachement du sénat au
statut militaire de la gendarmerie
ce projet de loi a été renvoyée au fond
à la commission des affaires étrangères
et de défense
notre collègue jean faure ayant été
désigné comme rapporteur
je tiens à souligner que jean faure et
moi même avons travaillé en commun tout
au lond examen de ce texte et je
voudrais ici le remercier publiquement
de cette totale disponibilité et de son
écoute les amendements les plus
importants adoptés par la commission des
lois sont pour la plupart identiques à
ceux de la commission de la défense
si le projet de loi est un texte court
dont l'objet est bien défini il faut
néanmoins remarquer qu'il s'inscrit dans
un ensemble de réformes de réflexion
plus large qui affecte ou qui vont
affecter la gendarmerie je citerai ainsi
leur attachement du budget de la
gendarmerie au ministre de l'intérieur à
compter du 1er janvier 2009 les
réflexions pour garantir la parité
globale de traitement et de carrière
entre policiers et gendarmes
le livre blanc sur la défense et la
sécurité nationale qui vise notamment
renforcer le lien entre sécurité
intérieure et sécurité extérieure la
future loi de programmation militaire
et naturellement la révision générale
des politiques publiques rgpp
la gendarmerie est donc à un tournant de
son histoire il convient de négocier
d'autant mieux
que l'existence de deux forces de police
dont l'une à statut militaire est un
atout dans la france ne peut et ne doit
se priver
en effet l'existence de deux forces de
sécurité intérieure est une richesse à
préserver la gendarmerie du fait de sa
vocation interministérielle et de son
positionnement à la lisière de
différents univers joue un rôle
important d'équilibrer c'est d'ailleurs
un moyen pour le gouvernement de se
prémunir contre tout mouvement de
contestation de grève de l'une des deux
forces
c'est aussi une garantie d'indépendance
et d'impartialité pour l'autorité
judiciaire qui dispose ainsi du libre
choix du service de police judiciaire
compétent
en outre cela crée une émulation entre
services enquêteurs et permet lorsqu'un
policier ou un gendarme est mis en cause
de saisir un service enquêteur
n'appartenant pas à son corps la
gendarmerie nationale assure aussi la
police judiciaire et la prévôté dans les
armées ce rôle particulier au sein des
forces armées
mais en dehors des armées explique que
la gendarmerie soit qualifié d' armes
ce positionnement permet la gendarmerie
de contrôler les armées à cet égard elle
est indispensable car les autres
solutions ne sont pas satisfaisantes
soit les armes et se contrôler elle même
soit cette mission incombe à la police
nationale qui ne disposent pas de la
culture militaire suffisante
l'existence de deux forces à
l'organisation et au fonctionnement
distincts est également nécessaire pour
faire face à des besoins différents
la police et la gendarmerie sont
compétentes sur l'ensemble du territoire
de la république notamment en matière de
police judiciaire et de maintien de
l'ordre
elles n'en n'ont pas moins des zones de
compétence privilégiées sur le plan
géographique à la logique de
concentration de la population et des
unités de la police nationale dans les
très grandes agglomérations s'oppose une
logique de maîtrise des espaces et des
flux pour la gendarmerie nationale ces
différences commande le choix de
l'organisation et du statut de chaque
force la maîtrise de 95% du territoire
par la gendarmerie suppose un maillage
dense de petites unités très
déconcentrer cette organisation requiert
une disponibilité totale que seul le
statut militaire
permet disponibilité qui applique à son
tour le logement caserne
si l'utilité du jihadisme policier n'est
pas contestable
il doit néanmoins être coordonnée et
rationaliser pour atteindre son maximum
d'efficacité
plusieurs écueils doivent être éviter
une concurrence exacerbée et des
rivalités les doublons la non
intéropérabilité toutefois il convient
que remarquer que ces écailles existe
également au sein même d'une force de
police ou entre plusieurs forces de
police tu sais tu civile
ils ne sont pas spécifiques au dualisme
français à cet égard la situation
française avec deux force principale de
sécurité intérieure est relativement
concentré par rapport à d'autres
démocraties comme le royaume uni
l'allemagne ou les états unis où chaque
agglomération où chaque länder dispose
de sa propre force de police
tout l'enjeu du projet de loi réside
dans cette double exigence préserver le
dualisme et renforcer l'efficacité des
deux forces
je croix madame le ministre que ce
projet de loi tel qu amendé par nos
commissions y parvient il pose des
garde-fous nécessaires
il ouvre la voie des coopérations et
synergie renforcée
le projet doit finances pour 2009 que
nous venons d'examiner prévoit
d'ailleurs de nombreuses mutualisation
toutefois là encore le souci des kids
toujours prévaloir la lutte contre les
doublons ou les défauts de coordination
aussi légitime qu'elle soit ne doit pas
faire perdre de vue les vertus du
dualisme la mutualisation des moyens ne
doit pas être recherché systématiquement
par principe car au final c'est la
spécificité de chaque force qui perdrait
sa justification
sauf exception la capacité à travailler
en commun ne doit pas conduire à
fusionner des unités ou services la
concurrence entre deux forces à la
condition qu'elles ne soient pas
exacerbé est aussi un facteur
d'efficacité ces remarques valent
également pour certaines des fonctions
support qui font l'objet des principales
mutualisation à cet égard je me réjouis
par exemple que vouziers confirmé devant
la commission des lois que la fusion de
l'institut national de la police
scientifique et de l'institut de
recherche criminelle de la gendarmerie
nationale n'était pas à l'ordre du jour
il me semble en effet
pourtant est indispensable dans ce
domaine de conserver deux organismes je
ne reviendrai pas sur toutes les
dispositions du projet de loi
mon collègue jean faure et vous même
madame le ministre nous avait déjà
présenté excellemment j'assisterai
seulement sur l'article 3 du projet de
loi relatif à l'autorité du préfet qui
fait l'objet d'une divergence personnel
de points de vue entre les deux
commissions
l'affirmation de l'autorité du préfet de
manière aussi claire et politiquement
importante même si l'essentiel du chemin
a été fait par la loi du 18 mars pour la
sécurité intérieure
elle dispose déjà que les presser dirige
l'action de la police et de gendarmerie
nationale dans le département et que
celles ci doivent lui rendre compte de
l'exécution de leur mission lors de
votre audition madame le ministre
vous aviez d'ailleurs déclaré que le
projet de loi ne change rien à la nature
des relations actuelles entre les
presser et la gendarmerie dans le
département
dans ces conditions il est certainement
possible de trouver un compromis
respectueux du caractère militaire de la
gendarmerie et de l'efficacité de
l'action de l'état dans le département
sous le bénéfice et d'observation et des
amendements adoptés la commission des
lois a donné un avis favorable aux
dispositions du projet de loi portant
dispositions relatives à la gendarmerie
de comptoir la parole est un monsieur
georges alain de rohan président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense des forces armées ce soit
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
les français aiment leur gendarmerie
elle s'inscrit dans leurs traditions
elle fait partie de leur paysage
elle est ancrée dans les territoires
puisque sa responsabilité s'étend sur
95% de superficie de notre pays et
couvre 50 % de sa population
les ruraux sont particulièrement
attachés à cette arme qui leur assurent
la sécurité dans la proximité
les contacts qu'elle a établis avec les
habitants et leurs élus repose sur la
confiance
une très grande connaissance du milieu
et de ses réactions
et ce sont ces liens très particuliers
qui font l'originalité et la force de la
gendarmerie
autant que les missions qui lui sont
confiées avant même le dépôt du projet
de loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui
notre commission avait décidé de
constituer en son sein un groupe de
travail chargé de réfléchir à l'avenir
de l'organisation et des missions de la
gendarmerie présidé par notre collègue
jean faure ce groupe de travail s'est
attachée à établir un état des lieux
minutieux des aspirations aussi et des
préoccupations des membres de la
gendarmerie
ce travail remarquable auquel je tiens à
rendre hommage a conduit jean faure l'a
dit à la formulation de 17
recommandations qui ont contribué de
manière très positive à éclairer notre
approche du projet de loi et je voudrais
également féliciter pour la qualité de
leurs rapports
nos collègues jean faure et jean patrick
courtois qui ont analysé avec beaucoup
de soin les dispositions de la loi et
proposer des amendements qu'ils ne
manqueront pas de l'enrichir
comme l'a indiqué madame le ministre de
l'intérieur lors de son audition devant
les deux commissions des affaires
étrangères de la défense des forces
armées et des lois
la réforme qui place la gendarmerie sous
l'autorité du ministre de l'intérieur
elle constitue un aboutissement et non
une rupture
cette novation a commencé en 2002
lorsque la gendarmerie par un décret du
15 mai 2002 a été placée pour emploi et
pour l'exercice des missions de sécurité
intérieure auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur après qu'en 2007 a été
établi une responsabilité conjointe du
ministère de la défense et du ministère
de l'intérieur sur la définition des
moyens militaires attribuée à la
gendarmerie et de son suivi
le projet de loi consacre le transfert
organique de cette armée sans
rattachement du gender au ministère de
l'intérieur
à compter du 1er janvier 2009 nous
faisons nôtre l'argument selon lequel ce
rattachement permettra de réaliser
l'unité de commandement des deux forces
de sécurité en renforçant leur
coopération et la mutualisation de leurs
moyens depuis 2002 d'ailleurs la
gendarmerie à la police qu opère au sein
des gir dans la lutte contre la
délinquance violente et les trafics
illicites et au sein de plusieurs
offices comme par exemple fils contre le
travail illégal
la mutualisation conduira à
l'acquisition de matériel commun dans le
domaine de l'armement au rapprochement
des fils et judiciaire dédié à l'analyse
criminelle à favoriser
l'interopérabilité des réseaux de
communication des deux forces à réaliser
des entraînements communs et à partager
lusage des hélicoptères en cas de
nécessité
on s'est beaucoup interrogé sur les
dangers que pourrait constituer pour les
libertés publiques
le fait de placer 2 149 mille policiers
et gendarmes dans la même main les ans
redoute que cette concentration n'altère
le caractère militaire de la gendarmerie
la ligne sur les modes de fonctionnement
de la police nationale ce qui pourrait
on l'a dit tout à l'heure mené à
certaines dérives
les autres souhaitent que soit maintenue
la dualité de la police judiciaire et
celle du libre choix du service
enquêteur par le parquet ou le juge
d'instruction d'autres enfin redoute que
les revendications des uns ou des autres
n'aboutisse à un alignement progressif
du statut respectif de ces forces
nous sommes unanimes au sun notre
commission à vouloir conserver le statut
militaire de la gendarmerie a été dit et
redit dans les orateurs qui m'ont
précédé la vanité statutaire des forces
de sécurité constituent une garantie
contre l'existence d'une super police
qui pèserait d'un poids trop lourd dans
l'état le statut militaire suppose que
les gendarmes quelques puissent être
leurs prérogatives soit soumis aux
règles qui réagissent les forces armées
toutes les forces armées la discipline
l'obligation de réserve
l'interdiction d'adhérer à un syndicat
ou un parti politique
l'interdiction de faire grève nous ne
voulons plus revoir les manifestations
choquantes et inadmissibles qui se sont
produites dans un passé qui n'est pas si
éloigné au cours desquelles des
personnels en uniforme et en armes se
sont permis de tuer leur hiérarchie et
je voudrais souligner la contradiction
chez ceux qui se déclarent des partisans
farouches d'égalité des forces de
sécurité tout en voulant étendre
gendarmes le droit syndical et le droit
de grève ce qui conduirait
inévitablement pour ses forces à ce
statut unique auquel ils prétendent
s'opposer
comme tout corps militaire l'efficacité
et la cohérence de l'action de ses
composantes repose sur le respect de sa
hiérarchie
il est logique que dans les départements
les forces de sécurité soient placés
sous l'autorité du préfet la loppsi a
posé le principe que le préfet assurait
la coordination de l'ensemble des
dispositions de sécurité intérieure le
décret du 29 avril 2004 est encore plus
précis puisqu'il dispose que le préfet
de département à la charge de l'ordre
public
nous sommes pas opposés à ce qu'il soit
précisé que la gendarmerie dans les
départements soit placée sous l'autorité
du préfet une autre commission tient
essentiellement parce que cette
prérogative s'exerce dans le respect de
la hiérarchie militaire il appartient
aux préfets de département de fixer au
commandement du groupement de
gendarmerie départementale ses objectifs
et ses missions mais le choix des moyens
et des modalités d'exécution revient
exclusivement à ceux liés à qui il
incombe de les mettre en oeuvre le
suppression de la procédure de
réquisition pour la plus grande partie
des activités de la gendarmerie
nationale nous a semblé raisonnable en
raison de la lourdeur de cette procédure
et de son inadéquation aux missions
ordinaires de la gendarmerie les
circonstances peuvent cependant conduire
à une intervention de grande ampleur des
forces de sécurité impliquant des moyens
lourds tels que les véhicules blindés
susceptible éventuellement entraîner
l'usagé des armes dans de telles
conditions il n'est pas possible de
recourir à de simples ordres verbaux
pour employer la force une procédure
d'autorisation nécessaire qui se
substituerait à la réquisition
complémentaire spéciale et dans les
modalités seront définies par décret en
conseil d'état
la parité de traitement avec les
policiers fait l'objet d'une forte
attente de la part des personnels de la
gendarmerie qui ont le sentiment qu'à
mission égal ou même parfois plus
nombreuses on observe un décrochage de
la rémunération par rapport aux
policiers si l'on veut éviter de
nouveaux remous au sein de la
gendarmerie
la création d'une grille indiciaire
spécifique aux officiers et
sous-officiers de la gendarmerie
nécessaire mais encore faut-il de la
mise en oeuvre de la grille n'aboutisse
pas à creuser la différence avec le
reste de la communauté militaire
il en est de même pour ce qui est des
instances de concertation de la
gendarmerie
les mécanismes de représentation des
personnels de la gendarmerie doivent
s'inspirer des principes qui prévalent
pour ceux des autres armes mais le
ministre de l'intérieur devra évidemment
participer ou est représentée au sein du
conseil de la fonction militaire de
gendarmerie il importe enfin que les
gendarmes maintiennent avec la
population de leur ressort un lien de
proximité constants une présence visible
l'organisation territoriale comme les
restructurations éventuels doivent
refléter ce souci et marqué que la
gendarmerie reste la force de sécurité
du monde rural et de ce qu'il est
convenu d'appeler aujourd'hui l'art
urbanité le transfert de la
responsabilité organique de la
gendarmerie du ministère de la défense
au ministère de l'intérieur nous ouvre
une nouvelle page de son histoire
à ceux qui redoutent que la
concentration des deux forces de
sécurité à une seule main ne mette en
péril les libertés publiques
on fera observer que c'est l'état de
droit et pas seulement le dualisme des
forces qui garantit cette liberté je
crois qu'on peut définitivement conjurer
le spectre de joseph fouché parce que
madame le ministre
comme vous n'avez été ni régicide nids
terroristes ni comploteuse on imagine
bien que vous ne mettrez pas vaut pas un
sa trace
la loi que nous examinons maintient un
triple spécificité administratives
judiciaires et militaires de la
gendarmerie en soulignant qu'à police
judiciaire constitue l'une des missions
essentielles de la gendarmerie le
législateur à l'initiative du rapporteur
notre commission notre collègue jean
faure rappelle très justement de la
gendarmerie est une force armées
institués pour veiller à l'exécution des
lois en confiant au ministre de la
défense la responsabilité de la
formation initiale de la conduite des
opérations militaires de la collation
des grades de la discipline le caractère
militaires de la gendarmerie est
clairement affirmée et maintenu l'emploi
par le ministre de l'intérieur de cette
force armée est strictement définies et
réglementé mais ce n'est pas seulement
dans les textes qu'il faut rechercher
des assurances sur le respect des lois
et des principes républicains
mais dans le comportement de ceux qui
sont chargés de les appliquer et dans la
conscience qu'ils ont de leur devoir
pour nous qui côtoyons les personnels de
la gendarmerie au quotidien nous
n'éprouvons aucun doute à cet égard nous
connaissons le respect scrupuleux de la
légalité et leur dévouement leur
professionnalisme la diligence parfois
le courage et le sang froid dont ils
font preuve dans l'exercice de leur
délicate mission
nous sommes convaincus qu'ils
continueront dans leur nouveau statut à
faire preuve des vertus qui leur valent
l'estiment et la confiance de la nation
alors dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est un autre collègue
madame anne marie escoffier
monsieur le président madame le ministre
mes chers collègues
j'étais pendant ce dernier week-end
auprès de nos amis gendarmes pour fêter
avec leur patronne sainte geneviève un
temps fort de solidarité et d'amitié
auxquels ils m'avaient associés c'était
pour moi l'occasion de prendre le pouls
d'une arme à laquelle vous le savez je
suis particulièrement attaché j'ai pu
mesurer en de nombreuses circonstances
les valeurs portées par la gendarmerie
rappelé dans un court film qui nous a
été présenté ce jour là un film qui
traduit parfaitement l'état d'esprit du
général gilles appelant six hommes à
être pleinement des militaires des
hommes du terroir des hommes de la loi
trois caractéristiques qui sont toute la
culture toute l'âme de la gendarmerie
c'est en raison de mon attachement à la
gendarmerie madame le ministre que je me
permets d'appeler avec la plus grande
force et avec une totale conviction
votre attention sur les difficultés que
je relève dans ce projet de loi le
premier problème je sais que je le
défendrai avec beaucoup moins de
véhémence que notre collègue était là il
ya quelques minutes monsieur jean pierre
raffarin qui vous a interpellé il ya
quelques jours lors du vote du budget de
la mission sécurité
il a dit son inquiétude de voir la
gendarmerie intégré le ministère de
l'intérieur et être placé sous
l'autorité du seul ministre de
l'intérieur n'ont pas de vous madame le
ministre
mais d'un ministre qui demain ferait fi
de l'indispensable dualité entre les
forces de police et les forces de la
gendarmerie
la séparation organique actuelle entre
police et gendarmerie est le garant des
principes
républicain que nous sommes nombreux ici
à défendre de toute notre âme deux
forces distinctes sous deux autorités
distinctes mais devront à la sécurité
des personnes et des biens
ce mode de fonctionnement est il si
inefficace qu'il faille le changer
n'avait-on pas et depuis bien longtemps
compris que police et gendarmerie devait
fonctionner en complémentarité n'avions
nous pas ni des modus vivendi qui ont
fait leurs preuves
les gir par exemple les redécoupages
territoriaux la fidélisation sur les
territoires urbains pour les uns ruraux
ou périurbain pour les autres depuis
2002 police et gendarmerie sont sous
l'autorité fonctionnelle du ministre de
l'intérieur et au plan local sous celle
du préfet chacun s'accorde à reconnaître
les bons résultats obtenus sans guerres
intestines
quel peut être l'apport de ce
rattachement
cette intégration cette fusion peut être
demain organique une meilleure
coordination
elle n'est pas affaire de structure elle
est affaire d'hommes une meilleure
gestion des ressources humaines
elle impliquerait une révolution
culturelle pour que chacune des entités
fasse un pas vers l'autre en matière de
déroulement de carrière de
représentativité dans des organismes
syndicaux ou non syndiqués de mesures à
caractère social une gestion plus
efficiente des budgets parce que les
budgets ne vont pas être confondus mais
qu'ils resteront chacun rattaché qui à
la dgpn qui à la dggn
ils garderont leurs spécificités propres
et surtout des niveaux décisionnels
distincts les uns haut niveau au nahd
escape les autres au niveau central avec
une gestion déconcentrée au niveau
régional la tâche des préfets pour
donner une cohérence
ça l'action des deux forces ne s'en
trouvera pas simplifier la détermination
des critères d'appréciation des
programmes et des bop police et
gendarmerie a d'ailleurs clairement
montré les limites d'un exercice de
comparaison quasiment impossible le
deuxième problème fondamental touche aux
prérogatives de la gendarmerie en
matière de réquisition
je voudrais redire ici les arguments de
deux anciens directeurs généraux de la
gendarmerie nationale ancien président
de chambre à la cour de cassation qui
ont dénoncé l'abandon de la procédure de
réquisition de la force armée fond dans
l'action de la gendarmerie de statut
militaire depuis le décret de 1903 il
écrivait il est insupportable au regard
des libertés publiques que la
gendarmerie nationale soit désormais
laisser dans les missions de maintien et
de rétablissement de l'ordre public à la
disposition du ministre ainsi qu'à la
discrétion des prêts faits sans la
garantie fondamentale de la procédure de
réquisition à forces armées au regard
des libertés publiques
il est à mon sens essentiel que la
gendarmerie forces armées institués pour
veiller à la sûreté et à la sécurité
publique chargée de la défense des
intérêts supérieurs de la nation soit le
garant de cet équilibre démocratique qui
passe par une procédure spécifique de
réquisition à forces armées renvoyer à
des décrets fusse-t-il en conseil d'état
les procédures d'autorisation en cas de
recours à des moyens militaires
spécifiques et d'usagé des armes à feu
pour les nécessités du maintien de
l'ordre est un artifice de forme en
aucun cas de fond un pied de nez aux
valeurs républicaines que je rappelais
il ya un instant
troisième point
il me faut souligner c'est celui des
conditions d'exercice de la gendarmerie
en milieu rural nul n'ignore les
engagements très récents pris par le
gouvernement en son entier et tout
dernièrement par le président de la
république lui-même en particulier au
dernier congrès des maires n'at-il pas
assuré les élus de sa volonté sans
faille de maintenir l'intégrité des
zones rurales dit maintenir à toute
force les services publics de s'opposer
à des mesures qui tendrait à réduire la
présence d'hommes et de femmes qui font
encore vivre nos territoires ruraux fils
des territoires disait le général gilles
des gendarmes
des gendarmes qui participent très
largement au quotidien à la vitalité de
ses terroirs qui se viderait n'était
l'énergie de nos maires ruraux des mères
qui acceptent aujourd'hui d'investir
dans des casernes 9 de gendarmerie qui
font d emprunt sur 20 ans sur 15 ans et
qui si l'on écouté que la mathématique
comptable verrez les effectifs de
gendarmes se réduire comme peau de
chagrin
faut-il vraiment aujourd'hui madame le
ministre
fixer la répartition des effectifs de
gendarmerie à l'aune des statistiques
sur le nombre de plaintes déposées sur
le taux d'élucidation des crimes et
délits
assurément les statistiques sont plus
favorables dans ces zones rurales que
dans les grands centres urbains
mais n'est ce pas là justement la
conséquence de cette présence précieuse
discrète permanente sur le terrain
d'hommes et de femmes en contact direct
avec nos populations rurales d'hommes et
de femmes de statut militaire
qui tiennent par dessus tout un ce
statut exigeant qui leur procure plus de
devoir qu'il ne leur rapporte de droit
qui est le fondement même de leur
culture celle de l'assistance à autrui
de la générosité du don de soi
je ne veux certes pas opposer leur
culture à celle des policiers et juges
et l'une par rapport à l'autre
elles sont différentes et il nous faut
enrichir leur complémentarité
c'est un objectif qui n'a pas besoin de
ce nouveau cadre de la loi
le groupe rds dans sa grande majorité
vous l'aurez compris madame le ministre
ne serait donné son aval à un dispositif
dont le souvenir à une période qui n'est
pas si lointaine laisse en chacun de
nous un goût par trop amer il croit
fermement à la sagesse d'un gouvernement
qui s'honorerait de garder deux forces
de l'ordre
gage de l' équilibre sur lequel doit
répondre reposer notre démocratie
la parole est à notre collègue daniel
renner
monsieur le président madame la ministre
j'avais écrit monsieur le ministre mais
je le retire mes chers collègues nous
voilà devant un projet de loi au
parcours un peu étrange enregistré en
août dernier au sénat est déclarée
d'urgence ils n'arrivent pourtant dans
cet hémicycle e qu'aujourd'hui mais il
est néanmoins en avance par rapport aux
dernières prévisions puisque il était
annoncé pour le mois de janvier prochain
en tout état de cause il arrive trop
tard par rapport à la loi de finances
qui a déjà entériné son approbation
puisque budgétairement la gendarmerie a
été rattachée au ministère de
l'intérieur
doit-on en déduire au fond que notre
débat d'aujourd'hui serait de pure forme
et ce serait une fois de plus une
mauvaise manière avouant le que le
gouvernement fait au parlement
j'ai lu que vous affirmiez sereine pour
défendre ce projet de loi ratifiant la
gendarmerie à votre ministère mais la
firme est ainsi les laisse à penser
qu'il pourrait y avoir un doute dans
votre esprit
car le ce ne serait pas totalement
illégitime
vous ne sembliez pas hier ministre de la
défense aussi favorable à ce projet et
depuis qu'on les voc de rencontres avec
les uns en audition des autres on ne
voit guère grand monde ça tousse
s'enthousiasmait pour lui
particulièrement sur nos bancs dans cet
hémicycle à gauche
certes mais dans les rangs de la
majorité on a cru le comprendre peu
d'empressement des critiques plus ou
moins exprimer demandez donc son
sentiment à l'ancien premier ministre
effectivement il n'est plus là l'ancien
premier ministre qui siège dans vos
rangs j'entends bien
nous l'avons entendu en commission en
l'état il ne voit très jamais un tel
texte et en dehors de cette enceinte
c'est plus d'incompréhension voire de
craintes pour l'avenir qui s'expriment
chez nos collègues élus locaux qui
apprécient la gendarmerie près de chez
eux et enfin chez les gendarmes eux
mêmes quand ils peuvent exprimer off
évidemment ce qu'il penserait et
pourquoi ce peu d'enthousiasmé
parce que s'il ne s'agit pas vraiment
d'une réforme historique depuis la loi
du germinal en 6 on l'a évoqué à
plusieurs reprises
aucune loi n'ayant été adoptée sur le
statut et les missions de la gendarmerie
depuis comme vous l'indiquiez devant nos
commissions des lois et des affaires
étrangères le 16 octobre dernier
il ne s'agit pas non plus d'un simple
texte de conclusions d'un processus
engagé depuis quelques années
car c'est bien une loi est la première
effectivement depuis 1798 qui rompt donc
avec une tradition by séculaire bien
établie dans notre république
à quelques exceptions près qui n'ont pas
été des périodes à retenir en matière de
libertés publiques
elles ont été citées 1er 2e empire
witschi pourquoi parce que cette loi
organise le détachement organique et
opérationnel de l'essentiel des missions
de la gendarmerie nationale de la
défense nationale en france et ça a été
dit je le redis deux forces concours à
la défense de la sécurité intérieure
l'une civile la police autres militaires
l'agent d'arnos car la gendarmerie est
une force militaire
pourvu de compétences de police est pas
une police à statut militaire
vous connaissez le débat
nous sommes attaché à ses principes et à
cette dualité police gendarmerie
ce texte là mais profondément en cause
en plaçant dans la même un la
disposition de ces deux institutions qui
concourent à la préservation des
libertés individuelles et à la sécurité
collective fondements du pacte social et
républicain
ainsi elle est à la fois au service de
la défense nationale du ministère de
l'intérieur et du ministère de la
justice
faut-il rappeler si l'article 66 du
décret du 20 mai 1903 qui est la charte
de la gendarmerie en plaçant la
gendarmerie auprès des diverses
autorités pour assurer l'exécution des
lois et règlements de l'administration
publique
l'intention du gouvernement de ce
gouvernement de la troisième république
et que ces autorités ne puisse en aucun
cas prétendre exercer un pouvoir
exclusif sur cette coupe
lors de l'audition que j'ai évoquées
précédemment je vous avais dit que pour
justifier expliquer ce texte madame la
ministre vous nous paraissait guère
convaincante car vous ne paraissiez
guère convaincu et je peux le comprendre
ce texte balance en effet entre les
contradictions pour tenter de convaincre
qu'on peut concilier les inconciliables
il détache la gendarmerie de la défense
nationale et affirme son statut
militaire
avouez que c'est contradictoire
l'article 1er résume à lui seul toutes
ses contradictions
la gendarmerie n'appartient plus aux
forces et service des armées sous
l'autorité du ministère de la défense
deuxièmement la gendarmerie nationale
est une force armées institués pour
veiller etc
autre exemple les commandants des unités
territoriales sont placés sous
l'autorité du préfet comment alors
respecter et faire respecter le rapport
hiérarchique principe fondamental de
l'institution militaire
quant à la procédure de réquisition
voilà ce qu'en pensent ils
leur dire parce que ça a son importance
d'anciens et éminent directeurs généraux
de la gendarmerie
il est surprenant il est insupportable
au regard des libertés publiques que
cette nouvelle armée de l'intérieur
riche de cent mille hommes disposant
d'unités blindées et désormais dans ses
missions et le maintien et le
rétablissement de l'ordre public soit
laissé à la disposition de son chef
ministre ainsi qu'à la discrétion des
préfets sans la garantie fondamentale de
la procédure de réquisition de la force
armée et plus loin ajoute et la
suppression catégorique de cette
procédure c'est dans l'article 2 pour la
gendarmerie ne peut être admise sous
cette rédaction
nous pourrions l'a qualifiée de
liberticide
voilà une appréciation très sévère et
porté par des spécialistes
il est bien vrai en effet que si la
réquisition qui fondamentalement et vous
l'avez rappelé tout à leur permet à une
autorité civile d'obtenir les moyens des
forces armées et c'est qu'elle n'est
plus une nécessité alors c'est qu'au
choix
le ministère de l'intérieur n'est plus
une autorité civile ou la gendarmerie
n'est plus une force armée ou alors
dernière hypothèse les mots n'ont plus
de sens le décret de mai 2002 en
confiant la responsabilité de l'emploi
de la gendarmerie uniquement au
ministère de l'intérieur pour les
missions de sécurité avait de fait
réduit la portée des textes fondamentaux
de 1798 et de 1903 qui eux demandé à la
gendarmerie de répondre aux
sollicitations des ministres de la
défense de la justice et de l'intérieur
n'ajoutez même de l'outre-mer à l'époque
ce n'était donc pas à vrai dire une
totale nouveauté
même si pour le ministre de l'intérieur
de l'époque il était important que cela
paraisse pontel police et gendarmerie
ensemble c'est plus de pouvoir
concentrer pour une seule personne
il se dit volontiers sous cape
que pourtant elles ont gendarmerie et
police des relations peu simple mais
elles ont poursuivis et approfondis ses
relations appris à réaliser leurs moyens
leur formation continue à échanger des
expériences méthodes et on pouvait très
bien en rester là mais ce n'est pas
votre choix
pourtant on a également pu à cette
occasion mesurer tout ce qui différencie
un policier d'un gendarme ni conditions
de travail rémunération le logement
l'action sociale les droits d'expression
des années deux autres et bien sûr le
sens de l'engagement militaire pour
mettre en oeuvre le transfert que vous
demandez et qui ne se résument pas
seulement l'aspect budgétaire
il vous faudra porter atteinte à l'unité
de la gendarmerie maintenir les ans hors
du champ du ministère de l'intérieur
gendarmerie spécialisées maritime de
l'air de l'armement et pour les autres
régler entre défense et intérieur de
multiples questions de soutien d'actions
sociales de santé
plus important encore de maintien en
conditions opérationnelles des
équipements pour lesquels d'ailleurs on
ne sait plus très bien où se trouvent
les budgets enfin ce qui concerne
proprement dit le personnel c'est-à-dire
les gendarmes
il y aura entre les deux ministères des
compétences transférées des compétences
partagées des compétences de murray
parfois les nuances pas restent obscures
ainsi en est il de la discipline 1
défense et la notation à l'intérieur
madame la ministre
pourquoi feu réponse simple quand on
peut faire aussi compliqué nous le
voyons bien en la détachant ainsi des
armes et la gendarmerie
on peut le craindre elle aura bien du
mal à conserver longtemps son statut
militaire
je sais que vous en défendez mais c'est
pourtant ainsi la loi que vous portez
aujourd'hui ouvre cette voie est attaché
que nous sommes aux deux forces de
sécurité nous ne vous suivront pas sur
ce chemin depuis une vingtaine d'années
l'organisation territoriale de ces deux
forces de sécurité a bien évolué elle
s'est adaptée à un nouvelle géographie
des collectivités aujourd'hui il partage
du territoire entre police et
gendarmerie paraît assez clair la
gendarmerie qui avait et qui a dans ses
missions la surveillance du territoire
et plus particulièrement destinés à la
sécurité des campagnes et des voies de
communication
c'est à dire l'article 1er du décret de
1903 pour ce faire elle s'est
réorganisée en regroupement puis en
communauté de brigades sur nos
territoires ruraux
d'une manière générale cette
implantation est maintenant comprise des
élus locaux est plutôt apprécié d'autant
que les relations entre collectivités et
l'ue et gendarmerie se sont au fil du
temps formaliser et améliorer il y a un
attachement évident à la gendarmerie
considéré comme acteur principal de la
sécurité et de la tranquillité des
habitants dans les zones rurales
mais je dois vous le dire ici madame la
ministre ce qu'ils craignent nos
concitoyens et les maires de nos
campagnes c'est le non remplacement des
effectifs
ce sont les rumeurs de nouveaux
regroupements de fermeture des brigades
et la baisse des effectifs annoncé
qu'elle soit inscrite en loi de finances
ou à cause de la rgpp pour eux il ya pas
de différence et à propos du texte qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui
il imagine bien qu'on pourrait alors
tellement plus facilement demander au
gendarme d'aller renforcer la police
dans des zones plus urbaine et délaissé
ainsi leur commune
voilà ce crime craignent voilà surtout
ce qu'ils ne veulent pas et on peut les
pauvres en conclusion ce qui importe
pour vous et pour nous c'est de
travailler à assurer convenablement sur
l'ensemble du territoire la sécurité
publique ou disons à quoi bon cette loi
une loi qui au lieu de simples
et compliquent ne peut pas être un gage
d'efficacité furent une loi qui conduit
la gendarmerie sur des voies incertaine
où elle pourrait perdre sa spécificité
son man même une loi qui rompt avec
notre tradition républicaine
enraciné dans ce pays une loi de crainte
est mal prise de beaucoup ne peut pas
être une bonne loi
vous aurez compris madame la ministre
que pour une telle loi vous ne
trouveriez pas notre concours la parole
est un autre collègue jo kergueris
les gens
ce président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues le débat qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui sur le projet de loi sur les
dispositions relatives à la gendarmerie
nationale fait suite aux réflexions
conduites par le groupe de travail de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
défense et des forces armées présidé par
notre collègue jean faure que je salue
ici
actualisant des dispositions
législatives et réglementaires un peu
daté le projet de loi permet d'adapter
cette arme aux nouvelles réalités
territoriales et sociales qui sont
celles de notre pays aujourd'hui
vous savez madame line is madame la
ministre comme le sujet est sensible à
la réflexion des parlementaires de
province des zones rurales dont je fais
partie car la gendarmerie est présent ou
squats ont même qu'elles y soient
omniprésentes et ce au quotidien
mais rappelons le aussi l'âge en abrite
aussi présente dans cette maison et
c'est l'occasion pour nous de saluer le
dévouement et la compétence des
personnels de la garde républicaine qui
veille à la sérénité de nos débats le
texte que vous nous proposez propose
d'abord à notre réflexion un
rattachement organique de la gendarmerie
nationale au ministère de l'intérieur à
partir du 1er janvier 2009
il ne s'agit pas là d'une inflexion
majeure
nous l'avons constaté depuis nombreuses
années un approche ans était déjà opéré
et ceci dans le cas d'une longue
évolution nouveau là seulement au bout
de cette évolution qui considère que le
gendarme avec son statut propre est le
complément du policier et vice versa
adam la milice ou serait désormais
responsable de l'organisation de la
gendarmerie de sa gestion de son emploi
et de l'infrastructure militaire qui lui
sera nécessaire mais
et cela est très important la
gendarmerie nationale d'autres l'ont dit
avant moi ici conserve son statut
militaire et il n'est nullement question
d'une fusion avec la police car
l'article premier du projet il bien
qu'elle demeure une force armée forces
armées dans les missions sont
parfaitement définis tant qu en matière
de sécurité intérieure police
administratifs maintien de l'ordre de
renseignement d'information de
protection des populations qu en ce qui
concerne ses missions judiciaires et ses
missions militaires
ainsi pour la première fois le texte
reconnaît l'une des spécificités
essentielle de la gendarmerie nationale
qui réside dans sa capacité de s'engager
dans les crises de haute intensité voire
dans les conflits armés
et dieu sait si tu les opérations
extérieures que nous vivons le
requièrent mais les officiers des
sous-officiers de gendarmerie reste bien
des militaires soumis au statut général
des militaires
il conserve bien leurs obligations et
leurs sujétions particulières auxquelles
sont soumis les militaires d'un jean
d'un prix national qui découle à la fois
de leur statut militaire et de leurs
marais de leurs missions de police et
notamment en matière de logement
casernes et que l'on doit considérer
convenons-en plus comme une contrainte
que comme un avantage
quoique le prétendent certains cependant
le projet de loi prévu de placer les
responsables locaux des services de la
police nationale et des unités de
gendarmerie sous l'autorité des préfets
dans un amendement qui sera soumis à nos
collègues la commission affaires
étrangères des forces armées a préféré
ne pas retenir cette expression car elle
estime que l'affirmation de l'autorité
des préfets sur les commandants locaux
de gendarmerie était susceptible de
porter atteinte au principe d'obéissance
et hiérarchique consubstantielle au
statut militaire de gendarmerie et je
pense qu'il faut soutenir cette position
de la commission
cette disposition vite
nouvelle vis-à-vis du préfet induit
nécessairement la suppression du
principe de réquisition des forces
armées pour l'emploi de la gendarmerie
au maintien de l'ordre alors donnez moi
de me rappeler que quand on parlait de
réquisition des forces armées c'était un
temps où pour maintenir l'ordre il était
aussi possible de recourir à la troupe
nous sommes quelques-uns ici à avoir
vécu des grands événements de 1948
l'organisation de maintien de l'ordre en
france compte tenu de la gendarmerie
module la présence de jean-marie mobile
des des compagnies de crs ne se fait
plus du tout dans le même contexte
donc ceci peut ne pas soulever de
problèmes insurmontables dans la mesure
où les commissions et des forces armées
et des lois ont préféré conditionné la
suppression de la procédure de
réquisition pour l'emploi de gendarmerie
au maintien de l'or à l'instauration
d'une nouvelle procédure d'autorisation
pour le recours aux moyens militaires
spécifiques comme les véhicules blindés
ou et par bon pour les pour usage des
armes au maintien de leurs tentes en ce
qui concerne les gendarmes que les
policiers ces amendements sont de nature
à répondre aux interrogations que le
gendarme se pose
il faut ajouter que l'objectif une
parité globale de traitement et de
carrière entre gendarmes et policiers
l'une des conditions de la pérennité du
statut militaire et les dispositions
concernant la reconnaissance une grille
indiciaire spécifiques vont dans ce sens
si elle conserve son statut militaire la
gendarmerie demeure en charge de la
prévôté militaire vis-à-vis des autres
composants de nos forces armées et les
attributions de l'autorité judiciaire
pour l'émission du même nom sont
réservés nos collègues de la commission
des lois ont aussi souhaité qu'il soit
inscrit dans le code de procédure pénale
le principe du libre choix du service
enquêteur par l'autorité judiciaire et
c'est un souhait que personnellement je
partage enfin le projet de loi propose
une gestion rénover des ressources
n en vous confiant madame la mise une
compétence de principes en matière de
gestion des ressources humaines des
personnels de gendarmerie partager à
chaque fois que nécessaire est votre
collègue de la défense
toutefois le ministre de la défense
continuera d'exercer les compétences
indispensables en matière de discipline
il est prévu de mieux reconnaître la
place et le rôle important joué par la
réserve avant de conclure je voudrais
attirer votre attention sur le jeu le
fait devant ma collègue marie payet ici
présents sur le sort des gendarmes
originaire d'un département d'outre-mer
dans certains de ces départements brute
pour sans tâche des gendarmes
appartenant d'origine à ces départements
et souvent modestes et ceci pose parfois
des problèmes de contact avec la
population de connaissances et pratiques
locales des mentalités voire de la lande
aussi à l'occasion du rapprochement du
statut police gendarmerie les militaires
originaires d'un département d'outre-mer
aimeraient bénéficier d'un statut
comparable à celui de leurs homologues
de la police nationale à savoir la
possibilité de pouvoir revenir chez eux
après une période passée sur le
territoire métropolitain qu'ils soient
moins longues que ce qui existe en ce
moment il y a là une préoccupation
légitime avec elle il serait souhaitable
que le gouvernement sera attentif en
conclusion sachez madame le ministre que
sous réserve expresse de le voir enrichi
des amendements déposés défendue par la
commission des lois par la commission
des des forces armées le groupe de
l'union centriste apportera son appui au
projet de loi relatif à la gendarme
et si la gendarmerie nationale demeure
bien dans ce projet je le disais tout à
l'heure une force armée
je forme le voeu qu'elle demeure comme
elle le fut pendant des décennies pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
mais aussi pour l'ensemble de nos
territoires présentent vigilante
bienveillante pour faire mentir cette
affirmation de paul valéry qui dit que
la faiblesse de la force est de ne
croire qu'à la force séjour